meilleur ouvrier de france une
distinction qui remonte à 1924 et qui
récompense elle les artisans qui
s'illustre dans la réalisation de leur
métier pour l'année 2011 on compte 233
lauréats dont 7 yvelinois 7 c'est le
chiffre de cette édition six hommes
parmi lesquels et christophe at-on
bonsoir à vous donc cuisinier est
également une femme une seule femme dans
le département c'est vous véronique à
bègles peintre sur porcelaine un mot
déjà sur ce prix à tous les deux c'est
pas un prix en plus c'est un diplôme
véritablement et puisqu'il ya un travail
qui est à fournir pour obtenir ce
diplôme
on va en parler mais déjà ça représente
quoi l'aboutissement d'un travail très
long et très difficile
oui très très long un aboutissement de
en fait je les présenter deux fois
c'était la deuxième fois et donc ça m'a
demandé beaucoup d'investissement au
niveau tant travail et qu'elle était le
travail justement à fournir pour obtenir
ce diplôme un dentiste pour le set
ce diplôme il fallait j'avais d'abord on
avait d'abord une première spéciale
première épreuve à passer devant un jury
donc on devait je devais pas une
assiette devant un jury néons qui noté
tous mes gestes et où enfin une fois que
ce
que j'avais acquis ce cette épreuve
j'avais une deuxième épreuve où je
devais par havas et une assiette une
assiette avec freeze et bouquets imposée
et le valls avait un sujet un peu plus
libre avec trois devaient 23 personnages
j'avais des difficultés techniques à
intégrer dans mon sujet ça faisait le
même temps ça s'est déroulée salle arts
vient de temps sur ce sur neuf mois sur
neuf mois d'août les jetons je les peins
de ces deux pièces en neuf mois
le vase marc présenté sur le vase même
250 r et plus le travail auparavant où
je devais réfléchir mais est ce que
j'allais faire le sujet était l'homme et
la planète reste un sujet très actuel
vous en est bien sorti puisque vous avez
obtenu ce diplôme christophe at-on
comment ça s'est passé pour vous alors
pour l'obtenir ce diplôme alors pour
nous l'écuyer ça se passe en deux étapes
principales une première étape où nous
étions un peu plus de six ans pour la
demi finale
première étape une étape une épreuve
écrite très rapide de technologies
professionnelles bien sûr culinaire
ensuite une épreuve de cuisine basée sur
deux plats avec un avec un plat à base
de
de deux filles et un repas de flétan
pardon je sais plus quoi sont d'ailleurs
fait un point ce serait en tout cas
voilà du poisson il plaint pas et de
canards c'est une cape la base de canard
donc ça à l'issue de cette demi finale
nous avons été 36 à rester en lice pour
la finale
et puis après la finale qui était basée
sur deux plats précis un turban de
haddock soufflé est un plat basé sur un
gigot d'agneau pic à l'ail avec
différentes garnitures puis un dessert
surprise finalement avec des techniques
imposées et au final donc une médaille
qui a été remise l'an dernier ça c'était
sur paris pour l'ensemble des meilleurs
ouvriers de france et puis dans le
département des yvelines il a eu cette
cérémonie qui s'est tenue hier soir et
nous étions présents à la rencontre des
autres lauréats du département un
reportage d'alice gastines et de
guillaume qu'en ce lieu
au revoir chaque jour ce technicien
d'atelier dans l'aéronautique fabrique
des pales d'hélicoptères en composite
mais cet après midi là il reçoit le
titre de meilleur ouvrier de france dans
la catégorie arts et techniques des
matériaux de synthèse
passionné de musique le jeune homme a
réalisé un saxophone uniquement en
carbone difficulté c'est que beaucoup
beaucoup de pièces sur un saxophone
en plus on m'a imposé une réduction
d'échelle donc moi je pensais par
l'échelle 1 mais du coup j'ai été
contraint de faire ça l'échec car un
vrai défi que florent roche du à relever
pour gagner ses lettres de noblesse
entrée sans diplôme dans un grand groupe
d'aéronautique
ils comptent gravir les échelons grâce à
cette récompense déjà au niveau 2
du statut au sein d'eurocopter donc
de mon travail il y a
il ya des évolutions meilleur statut
meilleur salaire forcément le concours
de meilleur ouvrier de france se déroule
sur trois ans les conditions diffèrent
selon les catégories mais une chose est
sûre sa renommée encourage les
générations d'artisans à venir c'est la
perfection bon on sait très bien que la
perfection n'existe pas mais ils sont
vraiment firmament de leur profession et
surtout reconnus par leurs pairs
un jeune qui demain aura comme maître
d'apprentissage un meilleur ouvrier de
france
pour lui c'est quand même quelque chose
de très important le concours créé en
1923 à l'initiative d'albert lebrun
récompensé à l'époque les meilleurs
compagnons du devoir
il est aujourd'hui ouvert à tous les
artisans dans 162 disciplines
différentes et parmi les lauréats une
autre versaillaise d'aironi caberg
peintre sur porcelaine et donc ses
diplômes qui ont été remis hier vous
l'avez en votre diplôme christophe à
tomber vous l'avez sur ce plateau je
voulais ce que montre à la caméra c'est
un grand diplôme voilà et il va vous
servir à quoi ensuite ses diplômes
maintenant ce diplôme mois pour moi ça
va être très simple il va aller dans mon
lieu de prédilection à la maison c'est à
dire dans la cuisine et dans votre
atelier en ce qui vous concerne
mais en tout cas sur le plan ensuite
pour pour votre avenir pour votre
carrière ça apporte quoi
alors je sais pas si ça apportera
quelque chose pour mon avenir en tout
cas ça pour moi c'est une reconnaissance
du travail accompli
mais ce à quoi ça va me servir peut-être
demain c'est pour la transmission dans
tous les cas à prouver que je suis
capable de transmettre aussi et ça
permet aussi de gagner en confiance en
soi et de se dire voilà j'ai réussi à
obtenir ce diplôme cette distinction on
voit également la médaille je sais que
vous l'avez sur ce petit faux pourra
l'apercevoir tout à l'heure voilà ça
permet de gagner en confiance également
de dire si je peux faire ça je peux tout
faire en confiance oui mais c'est à dire
que tous les jours où l'on travaille
quand même on doit se dire je dois être
irréprochable et être au niveau de
l'excellence
chaque jour dans le kentucky pression
supplémentaire
c'est pas une fin en soi c'est pas une
c'est une presse une forme de pression
mais c'est un plaisir aussi c'est un
honneur de porter le titre de meilleur
ouvrier de france tous les jours c'est
un plaisir et un honneur c'est sûr pour
vous également d'apporter cette médaille
la montre est ce que vous l'avez a mené
avec vous et voilà cette médaille est la
vraie raison c'est sa demande d'être
toujours très bon parce que l'on fait on
va s'intéresser à vos professions
justement à présent on va commencer par
vaux christophe at-on cuisinier vous
avez créé votre entreprise de chef à
domicile
vous êtes également professeur à l'école
tecomah justement vous parliez
d'enseignés de transmettre c'est
difficile à transmettre une passion
canton même jésus oui voilà quand c'est
une passion c'est pas difficile
les faux déjà fait dupe les actionner
aussi un petit peu à la base être faut
aimer son métier ce que les élèves et
les jeunes que vous voyez passer ont
cette passion est ce que tous ne l'ont
pas tous mais ceux qui sont un peu en
recherche de posture on peut les aider
justement à découvrir un métier tels que
la cuisine où on peut justement trouver
un tel bonheur que on est là pour les
aider dans tous les cas vous avez
commencé quand votre passion avoue alors
moi ma passion n'a pas démarrer tout de
suite j'ai pas choisi ce métier là c'est
mon père qui m'a eric limiers à diriger
mais au bout de quelques années j'ai
trouvé ma place
et puis voilà après je pense que j'ai
réussi à m'épanouir réellement est
également puisqu'on parle de l'accusé on
va juste faire une parenthèse pour
l'actualité la tva ça a été annoncé hier
remontera à 10% c'est concerne la
restauration également j'aimerais votre
réaction c'est l'occasion bah ça va être
difficile pour les entreprises ça il
faut pas le faut pas l'oublier c'est une
situation difficile pour tous les
restera pas tous les restaurateurs mais
une majorité des restaurateurs
aujourd'hui et je pense qu'il va falloir
être très prudent quant à l'application
de cette tva
c'est une petite parenthèse des à
l'actualité forcément je vous ai posé
cette question mais ce qui nous
intéresse ce soir c'est cette
distinction ce diplôme de meilleur
ouvrier de france où les mof pour les
initiés on va voir si les yvelinois les
saint quentinois sont initiés est ce que
vous savez ce que signifie mof c'est
l'une de nos questions du jour à quoi un
9 1 mof aucune idée non à moosch c'est
parce que c'est une meuf ouais je sais
ce que c'est mais un mof non je connais
pas c'est une expression qui sera en
rapport avec quoi la mode ou je sais pas
moi
fringues un style je suis pas
amorphes je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
un meilleur ouvrier de france
mais voilà je cuisine et vox collet
c'est un artisan déjà assez des valeurs
sûres auxquels on peut faire confiance
je pense donc voilà pour nos entreprises
ça serait bien sâr la bienvenue voilà
c'est quelqu'un qui
pour être précise je crois que sans les
artisans qui son compagnon et qui ont
fait un tour de france ou quelque chose
comme ça c'est un concours qui consiste
tout simplement à sur un grand concours
de cuisine en fait ya plusieurs
catégories la boulangerie à cuisine
glacier il ya beaucoup de catégories et
sa décerne chaque année le meilleur
cuisinier de france quoi c'est le petit
col bleu blanc rouge
ouais ouais voilà maintenant meilleur
ouvrier de france et ben voila j'ai
appris quelque chose aujourd'hui
vous l'avez un ce petit col bleu blanc
mais voilà sur votre veste alors pour
les professionnels ceux qui sont initiés
ça représente quelque chose
véritablement pour le grand public c'est
un peu plus difficile lorsque vous
décidez de passer ce diplôme c'est pas
forcément pour que le grand public sache
que vous êtes diplômé ça va pas vous
apporter un plus dans votre profession
par exemple non pas vraiment enfin moi
si ça me permettent de me situer et
situer par rapport à mon métier à savoir
je n'avais aucun diplôme
lorsque je faisais donc c'est vrai que
quand je remplissais des dossiers pour
des expositions on me demandait quels
étaient mes diplômes j'en avais pas et
là vous aurez ce diplôme est donc là
maintenant j'en ai reconnu reconnu par
l'état ce diplôme de meilleur ouvrier de
france
vous avez vous n'avez pas de formation
et pour autant cela fait trente ans vous
exercez vous êtes commencé quand j'avais
bu j'ai commencé un peu par hasard j'ai
rencontré une dame qui faisait ça donc
je me suis dit pourquoi pas j'ai
commencé et ça m'a beaucoup plu j'avais
un bac arts déco pour ça que je dessine
un petit peu et je me suis pris de jeu
donc j'ai commencé puis je voulais aller
toujours plus loin quand j'allais dans
les musées je me suis dit faut je peux
toujours à prendre jusqu'à ce que je
rencontre une autre meilleur ouvrier de
france qui m'a
qui m'a appris à aller plus loin dans ce
que je faisais tu entres sur porcelaine
est ce que c'est un travail qui est très
répandue elle c'est un métier qui
s'éteint c'est un métier qui se perd
malheureusement très peu en france à
limoges il n'a quasiment plus donc voilà
c'est une déception pour vous est-ce que
vous avez tout de même le sol envie de
passer le flambeau aussi parce que j'ai
30 ans vous l'exercez est ce que vous
voyez j'ai envié bon gdg quelques élèves
mais non c'est pas facile hein c'est pas
facile de vivre de ça là votre activité
vous l'avait débutée il ya 30 ans
aujourd'hui le pli à 30 ans je peins en
fait j'ai vraiment commencé il ya 15 ans
et donc à ouvrir véritablement un
atelier
oui ça fait une quinzaine d'années
aujourd'hui c'est plus difficile d'en
vivre qu'il y a quinze ans par exemple
ou ça a toujours été difficile a
toujours été un peu difficile donc c'est
véritablement avant tout la passion qui
vous a poussé plus la possible de
l'appât du gain ou bien faut trouver une
l'appât du gain avec ce qu'il a bien
compris ça n'a pas dégagé sans vous
allez vous voir dans votre atelier
justement voir comment vous travaillez
un reportage de catherine mulato un
dessin presque une photo sur porcelaine
un sens du détail ine véronique à bègles
vient de décrocher le diplôme de
meilleur ouvrier de france
ce qui va changer ses jumeaux dit j'ai
plus loin de faire d'erreur
modeste veronica baiguera elle a démarré
la peinture sur porcelaine un peu par
hasard dit elle d'abord diplômé d'un bac
arts déco la versaillaise s'est orienté
vers un tout autre métier
éducatrice de jeunes enfants sans perdre
de vue sa première passion et ce qu'il
avait séduit dès le départ aux côtés de
décors d'objets donner une âme un objet
il y avait aussi la partie un peu
technique a dépassé
c'est une des plus grandes difficultés
au démarrage parce que quand on prépare
la peinture ça peut les cahiers alors ça
rend pas ce qu'on veut les des couleurs
qui se mangent les autres quand on
travaille
l'or produit les métaux précieux
c'est autre chose avec des cuissons
différentes enfin il ya vraiment une
somme de connaissances à avoir
de loisirs véronique on a fait un métier
un métier très prenant je ne compte pas
mes heures la pièce de concours à clé là
ça se base j'ai mis plus de 250 heures
sans compter tout le travail d' approche
en fait pour savoir ce que j'allais
faire
j'ai passé deux mois dessus avant de
lancer sur la pièce m pour remporter le
concours de meilleur ouvrier de france
qui se déroule tous les quatre ans et
véronique à bègles a travaillé sur ce
vase et cette assiette un travail alors
à la frise avec des personnages et des
paysages un savoir faire complet je suis
contente que ça me permet de dire mon
jeu c'est un monde ibo deux des
meilleurs ouvriers de france qui sont
présents sur ce plateau ce soir le
plateau du 7 8 pour cette édition du 7
novembre pour terminer j'aimerais savoir
votre actualité ce qui vous attend dans
les prochaines semaines vous allez
retourner chacun en cuisine ou en
atelier et tourner la page c'est une
histoire qui s'est terminé avec cette
remise de diplômes hier soir alors
personnellement la page se tourne je
retrouve mes apprentis dimanche sur le
salon equip'hôtel qui a lieu à la porte
de versailles
tecomah y sera présent tous les jours du
dimanche au jeudi
qu est ce qui me concerne moi j'ai
préparé une exposition
voilà donc du travail encore qui vous
attend encore félicitations pour ses
prix ils sont sept meilleurs ouvriers de
france dans les yvelines a donc avoir
reçu ce diplôme
hier en préfecture à versailles merci à
vous est la suite du 7 8 7 avec de la
culture la chronique culture du mercredi
avec johanna soudry comme chaque semaine
blues et reggae au programme ce sera
juste après les images de la dernière
rencontre à des chocs ce d'elancourt
l'équipe de roller hockey qui a connu
une lourde défaite à domicile il ya
quelques jours comme nous le rappelle
anthony rech ce dimanche le gymnase
chastagner d'elancourt n'a pas pu
s'embraser lors du 64ème de finale de
coupe de france de roller hockey
la faute aux phénix de ris orangis
pensionnaire de nationale 2 soit une
division au-dessus d'isolant courtois
les joueurs estonien prennent rapidement
le contrôle du match
dépassés certainement par le rythme les
chocs sont sanctionnés à de nombreuses
reprises et encaisse la plupart de leurs
buteurs
mais l'essentiel était de faire tourner
le groupe et donner leur chance aux
joueurs qui ne jouent pas forcément
championnat comme le jeune gardien de
but des chocs ce benoît robin habituelle
doublure de mathias guy une expérience
ajouté à quelques déchets en sortie de
zone aux shoots ont rendu de nombreux
palais au phénix elle éprouve un travail
à ça va être notre sortie de zone
notre placement défensif
et puis aussi jeu quand on shoote à la
cage touché la cage on ajouté à des tas
de moments ce qui était positif c'est
qu'on à nouveau l'intensité physique on
a répondu à jeu égal avec une n2 donc ça
c'est très positif
après c'est sûr que il faut qu'on marque
plus
il faut que je sais vraiment plus à la
plage ça ça a été un ca t1 des fossés
franche et d'argent les sharks ont pu se
rendre compte de l'écart de niveau entre
les deux championnats même si à
l'arrivée le score est un peu sévère 12
à 2 la parenthèse coupe de france s'est
donc vite refermée place au championnat
qui reste la priorité des joueurs de
benjamin ferran